hey guys welcome back to the Spates
wattle ad podcast time surely talk sport
Rugby World Cup preview and if you've
got a better name for that let me know
on the Instagram page because that is an
absolute mouthful but we are at the
moment we have been waiting for 2023
Rugby World Cup is almost here feels
like we've been counting down this date
for a very long time and of course I do
have my man with me the man with the
most iconic voice in New Zealand sport
most people claimed last week he's over
there in front soaking it all in how I
am yeah good good to be over here on the
ground the old Waterland media pass
still hasn't arrived but uh fair to say
got stuck into a few cold ones last
night so yeah perks are the job I guess
being being the roving reporter uh yeah
a good night last night we're looking
forward to the cup getting underway
what's the buzz like over there yeah
it's starting to build I think most of
the kiwis and Aussies and that will get
here today the Thursday
um speaking to like the Uber drivers and
stuff they have no idea what's going on
night they're just football mad they
just love mbappe they just want to talk
about soccer but I was trying to tell
them they're good so they should care
about it and that kind of got them a bit
more interested but we bumped into a
couple rugby fans over here and they
were fizzing for it just saying that
DuPont's the best player in the world
which is hard to disagree with yeah yeah
I was trying to tell them they're in for
a shock but we'll soon see mate you're
doing a hell of a job as the well-led
reporter over there I'm proud of you
it's good to see you out in in the mix
over there so good stuff keep that on
but obviously we've got no games to
review from the weekend so we'll go
straight into the preview starting with
the big one that you're going to be
obviously on the sideline for All Blacks
vs France the lineups are out so we can
go through a few of these no Geordie
um Anton's in
um a few big changes what do you make of
these teams mate yeah the rumors broke
obviously during the week that Jordy was
gonna miss out with a bit of a knee
[__] and unfortunately that's the case
I'm pretty gutted for him just because I
think ever since he's moved to 12 some
18 months ago he's been unreal there and
he's really made that Jersey his own I
think he adds another dimension to our
team in terms of his playmaking he's
like a third first five out there but
we're so lucky that we have guys like
Anton and David Harvey that you can call
upon because what a luxury that is you
know they're world-class footballers
Anton started in so many big tests so
it's just that next man mentality and
another cab off of the rank and a
quality footballer so yeah I'm I'm
stoked we've got those two in the side
gutted for Geordie I think the biggest
loss potentially is that no Shannon
Frizzell
um I just think his physicality in these
big games up against these big four
packs I felt like he was one of the most
missed players against South Africa and
I was really hoping that he'd be back
for this game but at the same time your
boy Kelly Dalton's gets a crack and I
think you know he's been unreal at Super
Rugby level for so long now and this is
his channel to kind of own that sixth
Jersey so I'm really excited for that as
well what did you make of the 23 yeah
it's an interesting point how they spoke
about um they wanted to play a quicker
game especially with Dalton at six so
um interesting Dynamic there they want
to try and play fast tempo Anton Leonard
Brown I I thought they might have gone
Davey at 12 but
um he's obviously only played sort of 40
minutes for Tasman so and they probably
feel like he might just be slightly
underdone and obviously the big news of
today or yesterday was naruta ruled out
for the comp so who they're going to
call in for there obviously that's all
being rumored at the moment whether that
is Ethan Blackadder he's going to make
his appearance over this sooner rather
than later just with the split they've
got they've already got Caleb Clark
DMACC Geordie not playing this week and
I feel like they've got enough depth
there but they could go someone like
shooter who's probably the next cab off
the rank unless they go to a Dallas
McLeod with I'm a bit more of that
Midfield cover so I'm predicting they're
gonna go Ethan it might be semi-final
who's actually over there as well I
think so he was arguably the next cab
off the rank at the time but watching
Ethan play for Tasman on the weekend
geez that got me excited and I just
think he's far too good not to be at a
Rugby World Cup who do you think you're
obviously good mates with shooter so
you'll be hoping he's over there for a
few more tickets for you yeah yeah
obviously on a personal level hoping
he's getting over here it's expensive
over here mate so they could turn the
boy over he's got the big match fees you
know so you can shout a couple cold ones
but I tell you what if even Blackadder
makes the plane that has to be the best
big call you've ever made it would have
happened within seven days that would be
unreal I think that that's a legit shout
too because I think he's one of those
guys that you can Chuck straight into
the starting lineup and you'd get
everything from him straight away
obviously if he was healthy he'd be over
here or if it was healthy the whole year
sorry he would have been over here
already so I think he's an instant guy
that you can Chuck into the
entertainment is ready to go so yeah I
think it could have been a great call
from you mate I can see that smile on
your face you're hoping it comes through
just for the bragging ride you're acting
like I it's the first one I predicted oh
here we go
right I've been on fire since we started
this thing that's why we've got so many
people tuning in and appreciate everyone
for listening but what are your key mean
for this game who's going to decide it
for you I think obviously regime is
going to be key I think we need to play
that fast tempo like you mentioned
that's the mindset going in I think Jaco
Piper will allow us to do that Ida
crunched a few numbers call me the poor
stats man but I think 88 winning record
under him we've only lost one game with
him in the middle so wow yeah we love
having yaako as a ref he kind of gets
the way we want to play so I think just
that dual pivot is going to be key
hopefully we can just get fast ball play
on the top of them and then we'll be
unstoppable but obviously that old key
up front it's going to be a massive
battle so I'm looking forward to
watching our Ford pet go to work I think
they'll have a real chip on their
shoulder right from being dominated
against the South Africans and we
obviously saw the reaction from the Kiwi
fans we're pretty quick to criticize but
like you mentioned they're probably
holding a fair bit back so I think we're
going to see a Fired Up Performance yeah
mate that's going to be a massive battle
up front and what a step from you by the
way 88 with yucco and Charles I love
that from you it gives me a little bit
more confidence the guys I think are
going to sort of be a big part of this
game is the wing is to be fair I'm
looking forward to the battle to know I
think's the best offensive Winger in the
comp All Blacks will have to be careful
how they attack down his Edge loves
getting in that passing Lane he'll be
looking for intercepts or shutting off
overlaps so that battle on the wings is
going to be really interesting
especially with the way our Wingers are
defending at the moment still passive D
which gives me a fair bit of anxiety
around how we're defending on the edge
we've got guys like and will Jordan who
can defend really well on the edge but
looks like they've just been told to be
really passive and make sure they're
getting to that last man so that's a
little concern for me watching but
um The X Factor that both of those guys
provide Mark Talia and will Jordan and
in the air as well it's going to be
important battle to be winning so
um I think they're going to be the key
guys that play a big part in this game
as well but like you always mentioned
that battle up front is going to be
crucial what are you predicting what's
your score and give me your first try
score because I did see not just fantasy
Rugby's out but also
um like a predictor game as well where
you pick a winning team and the score
and a first try scorer so we'll go with
those because
um we'll start there yeah I obviously
I'm backing the All Blacks today I think
it's going to be close though what score
did you go off the top of my head
chucking it out there now I'd probably
go about at 23 15 23 12 type of setup I
think it's going to be reasonably low
scoring and that first half is going to
be a real battle I think we'll kind of
get them from that 50 minute onward mark
But the key thing for me that I'm
worried about is the heat over here like
it's crazy at the moment I think come
kick off it's going to be still 29
degrees it's 34 35 during the days which
obviously takes a bit of acclimatizing
too so hopefully the lads can go the
full 80 because just walking around
she's nasty enough let alone playing a
full game of footy but I'm hopefully
hopeful that we'll get them in the
second half first try scorer let's go
with the little Rico yoani special why
not yeah yeah maybe Anton dishes them up
one perfect try so that's just to settle
the nerves early
already well am I unpredictor I've gone
for the All Blacks by seven and I went
will Jordan the safe option to score the
first try the man loves a try and he'll
get us Finn up for sure
uh next game obviously Italy versus the
Libya
um what do you make of this game I think
this is a great chance for Italy to show
that they are a step up from what they
have been in the past we were talking
about it last week saying that they're a
good football side but they probably
won't push your All Blacks in your
fronts as close but still demand the
respect and I think people will realize
this weekend once they put a score on
the Nubia that they are a genuine
football side so yeah I think they'll do
them in that kind of 30 to 40 Point
range
um oh mate you're right on I've gone 35
exactly so hey we're insane split your
man we're in sync mate I love this
that's a good sign who's your first try
scorer oh I actually haven't looked at
the team to be honest I'd actually had a
couple cold ones last night and that
really uh preoccupied my time maybe you
could tip me in one here mate the guy
I've gone is Monty Juani but like you I
haven't seen their side so another big
gripe here with um world rugby and I've
said it before in Super Rugby
why can't we name these teams earlier it
breaks me that we can't see these teams
all the all the players are named they
all know who's who's playing but they
just hold it off for everyone else
doesn't give us a chance to pump up the
game uh it's terrible for Fantasy rugby
because I'm trying to organize my squad
and I only can see three squads out
there we just need to know early and
there's no reason why they don't share
that any earlier so there's my first
gripe of the World Cup we need to make
the teams released earlier yeah I feel
like this is a 2022 Super Rugby gripe
that's been carried over made so it's
good that you can vent it on here but I
agree like a team was Tuesday like
they're doing the NRL like you mentioned
the players they find out on the Monday
right probably even before that they get
the nod that they're starting so it's
not like you're gonna shock anyone by
naming your team like everyone can kind
of work it out plus the rumors go out
early doors of who's playing anyway so
you may as well name it yeah 100
hopefully they hear this and make some
changes before the end of the world cup
now that would be powerful from the
water lad podcast surely now the next
game we called a bigger score on that
one Italy and anivia I'm predicting the
biggest score of the weekend and this
next one Island vs Romania
what are you predicting here yeah I
think this is going to be big as well
unfortunately they're saying it's going
to be 34 degrees during this game so
again extremely hot but I'm expecting
the Irish to make a real statement here
as well I feel like they're being
underestimated in a weird way a lot of
people are kind of saying that South
Africa France All Blacks but I mean
people have forgot how good Island have
been and in a weird way I almost hope if
the All Blacks can't do it that the
Irish can get up just as a bit of a
reward for their dominance during this
world cup cycle because they've been so
good so I expect them to make a real
statement here and maybe in that
50-point margin I've gone 45 was my
exact margin on that thing and I've gone
James Lowe to score the first try so on
the left wing loves loves to roam as
well he'll be busy
um and no doubt he'll be in my fantasy
side when we get to that bit a little
bit later but I agree with you around
the Irish like no one's really talking
about them um they're definitely sliding
under the radar once we get to
quarterfinals I'm sure everyone will be
standing on notice but I rate them as
like when you watch them play they're
one of the best teams in the world hands
down
um could easily go all the way so
um they're not a team of Oz All Blacks
I'd be wanting to play in their
quarterfinal to be fair so
um yeah it's going to be interesting and
yeah I don't know much about Romania
it's another one that I'm gonna look
forward to learning about over the world
cup but um Ireland have picked a pretty
strong side so I can see them running
away with that with a big score but the
next game Australia vs Georgia now this
is an interesting one it's when you look
at it initially you think oh easy one
for Australia but Georgia a pretty good
side
um they're ranked just below Australia
on the world rankings what are you
picking here I think Aussie will get
them maybe by 15 to 20 and it'll look
fairly comfortable on the scoreboard
towards the end but I think it's going
to be a real battle for them obviously
that Ford pack for Georgia is just gonna
rip into them and this is one of those
games where you can suffer a big injury
because it's going to be physical so I
think Eddie Jones will be nervous about
this one I'd love to see Georgia get up
and get the win that would be massive
and there'd be nothing better than
seeing the Aussies go down in week one
because geez would they panic but yeah
I'm expecting in that 15 to 20 Mark
those these will be too good over the
duration of the game but I think they'll
be really pushed and you'll be straight
to that press conference if Georgia
we're 100 oh mate well you've already
since I I've packed the boxing gloves
I'm ready to go I'm just waiting for the
approval to come through from you but
yeah I'll be baiting him of course the
waddle ad fans get to send through
whatever questions I ask so I'll be
expecting some doozies and yeah Eddie
will be expecting me as well because
he's a big fan of the show so he'll be
keeping an eye out I don't know if he
will be after Monday because I had Danny
Cipriano on on the weekend and he's told
a few home
Jones and I can see that in all in the
papers at the moment as well what a
couple of Snippets that have come out of
his book so not sure if it is going to
be a huge Woodland lad fan after that
episode on Monday but it is a good one
so stay tuned for that one but this
margin you went 15 to 20. this was the
first time we're a little bit off sync
because I've gone Aussie by 14. here we
go
close
exactly all right we've got work on
which is good you can't be nailing it
first up so I'll take that back to the
drawing board but you obviously think
it's going to be really tight as well
yeah I think it's going to be tight
initially as well I think there's going
to be probably two moments of Brilliance
from that Aussie C side that will um
break the game open and get them the
Victory and first try scorer now I
really struggle with his last name but
Mark the right winger hit me with it
because it's such a hard one to read
yeah I battle with that one as well but
Jeezy's a freak of a footballer and I
think yeah we saw it through Super Rugby
that he was talented but I almost feel
like he's taken his game up to another
level he's so dangerous he gives me like
Mark Talia Vibes he always beats that
first offender and likes to get quite
busy around The Ruck as well which I
rate from a Winger so yeah I I rate that
shout I also think Karen Betty's always
a good call as well just because he's
built like a brick I was speaking to
shoot her about his debut and he just
said he tried to put a shot
maybe the old Georgians are gonna find
out that you don't want to put a big
shot on that bloke yeah mate he looks
absolutely made of rock that guy is
incredibly powerful so it's a great
shout as well the Wingers they're always
a good chat when you're doing these um
first try scorers in these tapping comps
because
um they obviously score more than anyone
next game
England versus Argentina now this is a
tough one England have come in very
scratchy Argentina have been playing
some pretty good footy who are you
picking here I think Argentina are going
to get them if feral was in this in the
team then I'll probably be back England
to get it done but wow I I haven't liked
what I've seen from them over the past
kind of two months I feel like the
Public's turned on them a little bit as
well and you can't help but feel the
pressure so I think Argentina are going
to come in obviously with their Underdog
mentality but I believe they should be
favorites and I'm backing them to get
the win I think it'll be close and that
three maybe five point margin there'll
be one score in it but I'm back in
Argentina to pull this one off and
they're such a passionate side I think
this is really going to ignite their
world cup and they'll go on to win their
pool mate it's like you've got my login
to my tapping thing I've got Argentina
by three you're Horizon
this is crazy
full transparency as well I don't I'm
just wrong
whatever you're doing you should do this
every week but I've gone Pablo for first
try scorer um absolute lad wasn't really
sure obviously their team's not out so I
couldn't see
who's on their wings or anything but I
know Pablo will be in there and he's
always good on the edge and can get into
the tight stuff as well so he's a good
chance to score a try but like you say
England are under so much pressure I can
see this game sort of going two ways
like you get to the end of it and say oh
England they're back
um so I put in a really good performance
there they're going to be a hard team to
be or England are basically done I think
if they lose this they're going to
really struggle to get out of their pool
so massive game for them first up so one
I'll be watching with a lot of interest
and another game I'll be watching with a
lot of interest is obviously Woodland's
second favorite team Chile up against
Japan so um obviously there's a few
chili um listeners listening to it this
time I check the ratings we're not on
the top ten yet but that's the goal
throughout the podcast to get Chili's
number one rugby podcast and to start
off with Japan what are you picking well
I think we spoke about Japan the other a
day that they're not quite the side they
were in that last World Cup cycle so I
expect Japan to be too good but I think
Chile will probably get a bit closer
than a lot of people expect it was great
to see the Chileans just flood in
they're massive on their water land like
yeah current players commenting me which
is huge so you're right tapped into the
Chilean rugby scene but yeah I think
Japan will get them again probably in
that 15 to 20 point margin I think it's
going to be a little tighter than people
expect yeah okay I've gone seven more
than you there I've gone Japan by 27.
um I think they just got too much X
Factor across their board
um but like you say Japan have been
struggling I think this game might give
them a little bit of confidence
um 27.1 margin uh pretty happy with that
I've gone masarawa the dangerous man out
on the outside
um to go first try but yeah like you
said it was surprised to see a few
Chilean players jump into the world LED
support and I might have to try and get
one of them on for the preview show
throughout the world cup surely yeah
live cross I can meet up with them over
here
you know
warm up the throat and then go from
there oh how good would that be oh
that's podcast goals um okay and the
next game is
um a massive one actually for both sides
toughest pool of the competition South
Africa and Scotland
um what's your thoughts here
yeah my big call the other week was that
I think Scotland could really push them
and I I had them on my on my bet slips I
thought this is paying way too much I'm
gonna jump on board but after seeing
that performance last week from South
Africa it's kind of got me backtracking
a little bit I'm hoping that Finn
Russell the bloke you said I look like
can pull the strings in there have you
had any um comparisons to them yeah has
anyone no one's no one stopped me in the
street unfortunately but I need to get
some Scotland kit and start wearing it
out you know I'm thinking maybe a track
suit even though it's boiling hot just
the really Ram home that I'm Finn
Russell so I'll be heading out to the
merch store today to see what I can get
my hands on but I've seen a few South
African fans head to toe in their kit so
they're always passionate and I expect
that they will get the job done but I
think it's going to be a seven pointer I
think it's gonna be tight and then maybe
last 20 minutes South Africa will assert
the dominance like they often do with
that bench coming on one to 2030 they'll
be too strong but I'd love to see
Scotland get up here they're one of
those sides that I really enjoy watching
play footy they are willing to chance
their arm and roll the dice and I think
that that makes for a great watch but
unfortunately I think the South Africans
will just be too clinical how about
yourself yeah I'm fully with you after
Fords can dominate like they have been
with that African pack they should just
be able to grind down
um the Scottish side and a pure test
match footy but and if Scotland can play
high Tempo
um in the heat like you said it is over
there that might suit them and they'll
might be able to get some quick ball and
sort of get that pack running around a
little bit obviously they bring on their
second pair just after half time but
they have gone for two backs this week
There's a massive uproar about that um
7-1 split last week weirdly I thought
um it was fair play and a high risk move
like as a coach if you lose one of your
backs early you're a you're on a fair
bit of trouble and sometimes you do lose
two or three and they would have they
could have had all sorts on their
backline
um taking that risk but some people
calling it to be illegal or
um all sorts of stuff going on but um I
think it's fair play and I see they've
gone for two backs on the bench this
week so a little bit uh more common but
still quite unusual most teams would go
the three yeah I noticed I think it was
quagga Smith who came on to the bench
right as the seventh Ford and he was
wearing like Jersey 24 was that a really
late call perhaps did someone go down
like the day before in training or
something it seems like maybe it was it
was a late shift because surely you'd
get a jersey yeah that's a good point
now I didn't I didn't notice that at all
I just saw the big uproar about it so
yeah it probably makes more sense than
anything they would have had one bet go
down in the warm-up and he was probably
the only one ready to go who didn't have
a massive night with surely the night
before but it can get you you're only
human
and I've got Malcolm Marx for the first
try screw I feel like it's going to be
on the back of
up in that corner I don't think the
Scottish Mall deal will be quite as
strong as the All Blacks one in the
weekend even though they were giving
away a fair amount of penalties
um just keep that line clean
um I think he'll cross over at the back
of a mall so there's my Shout
in the next game Fiji Wales now this
um obviously months has been ruled out
guttered for him World Cup we just
talked him up all last week around how
good it was to for Fiji to have him at
10 running the cutter he's looking good
um obviously um Titi Talia will come in
um the other team he can play as well so
um I don't think it's going to affect
them as much as everyone's sort of
talking but
um because geez they've got some
dangerous backs and Lucy's who can play
on the whole 15 who can just play footy
what are you picking yeah I think if
Wales want to get and allow them to play
Fast footy then they're going to be in a
world of trouble so
they've kind of lost their Underdog
Factor beating England in a great like
it was an amazing result but at the same
time now whales are going to be on high
alert because they know that the fijians
are the real deal it would have been
kind of nice if they'd just come in
under the radar and really ambushed them
and pulled off the upset then but I'm
I'm still backing Fiji I think they can
get the job done you mentioned monsters
out and that is heartbreaking because
he's been so good for them and just
listening to their coach speak you can
tell that as a team they're gutted as
well so I thought uh Ben volovola North
Harbor great might have got the call up
not to be but I'll back them to get the
win in that three to five point range
again I think it's going to be really
tight but I'm backing Fiji now they seem
so much more of an 80 minute side than
in the past you know you almost trust
them to get these big wins so yeah I
think they'll start their World Cup in
the best way possible how about you I'm
agreeing with you again mate geez we've
we've agreed on everything I've gone a
slightly bigger margin of seven but I
think Fiji will be
um I think one thing that will suit them
is going to be that heat that's over
there because um obviously as a crusade
as we went over to Fiji where it was hot
and geez they love playing in the heat
so I think that'll really suit them a
lot more than it would the Welsh side so
um and I just think they've got so much
X Factor across their back line first
try score I've gone for our man her
bossy he can create something out of
nothing but man they've got the likes of
Raja and all sorts in their squad ready
to create absolute Havoc so it's going
to be a hell of a battle um whales are a
good side I thought they played well
against England
um in their warm-up games but I think
Fiji will get the job done and show us
why they're the number one ranked side
in that pool no for sure I'm looking
forward to this game in a way it's
outside of that all blacks French game
it's it's the game I'm looking forward
most to watch watching just because of
their fijians you never quite know what
they're gonna dish up so yeah I can't
wait for that one Sunday morning my time
should be a good watch or Sunday night
my time actually should be good okay
well the one thing that I really did
want to try and give you listeners a bit
of insight to is this fantasy rugby game
so so stoked to see a fantasy rugby game
with
um world rugby setting this up for the
World Cup gives you a massive interest
into the games awesome with mates trying
to challenge them who's going to finish
on top um I just being able to follow a
player throughout a game and watch watch
them as they make big plays or mistakes
and really ride home their performance
as you watch the game so I guess there's
a few key rules that I was pretty Keen
to share because
as I've seen through this going through
the fantasy thing that there's a few
things that people have missed by the
looks of it by looking at the most
selected players so I guess the first
rule to understand with this fantasy
rugby is that you have unlimited trades
which is very unusual for a fantasy game
most times you'd get two or three per
week this fantasy you've got unlimited
trades every week so you can basically
fully change your side every single week
depending on matchups it's pretty
ruthless mate you can uh play the
ultimate selectors here hey if someone
doesn't live up to the hype you can cut
them but also I quite like it because
there's quite a few teams especially in
this first week that aren't lacing up so
it gives you the ability to roll out a
whole new 15 and in week two once these
teams play
um me personally I'm always always
battle with the trades always blow them
early so it's it's great to see this it
should help out some rookies as well I
think people that are playing for the
this time that could end up being their
best friend yeah 100 because because
like you said the buyers teams are going
to rotate so much when they play the
Lesser teams
it would have been really hard to put a
number on the trades um I think what
they've done is probably right make it
unlimited but um you've got to make the
most of that by playing the match-ups
every week so I'm seeing a lot of guys
plan the the Stars loading their teams
up with the best team
um that they're hoping to just carry
through their whole comp but you may as
well find the match-ups each week and
just fully change your site on I think
in round one obviously you're going to
want Italians Irish Japanese and maybe
to an extent Australians but more those
first three because I think that's where
the points will be lying especially with
their Irish side so
um yeah I've loaded up there and my
captain is definitely Irish we'll get to
that soon but the second thing is I
guess is the point scoring system so I
guess the notable points to mention is
that it's 15 points for a try which sort
of sets the scene and you've got nine
points for a try assist which is usually
scored as the last pass it'll be
interested thing to make watch that over
the first few rounds to make sure that's
how it's
awarded line breaks seven points so
which basically makes a line break try
22 points instantly checking a few
Defenders beat along the way we're
looking at some big scores also one
point for every 10 running meter
um I think five for an intercept as well
so an intercept try we beat a few
Defenders you're looking at a big almost
a 50-point play so there's some big
points to be made especially on the
attacking side but what I like about
their scoring system is they've evened
it out with for the locks and the props
by giving you five points if you get a
line out turnover don't often see those
in games uh in Fantasy games so if you
can pick someone who's going to pick a
few line out says some points to be had
and every line out takes obviously one
point flankers are getting their points
with turnovers four points for a
turnover one for a tackle and obviously
the front row now they get points as
well if they get a scrum win they get
three points the whole front row so
they've tried to spread it across quite
evenly I think they've done the scoring
um really well on the on the comp on the
game so looking forward to seeing how
these first few weeks pan out and what
do you make of those scoring options
yeah Rider and obviously it makes the
game adds another level of interest to
it you know you could be parked up on
the couch hoping that Australia can pull
off the line out turnover against
Georgia and making a real scene when
they do because these five points in the
bank so it kind of gives you that extra
investment and makes you ride home the
smaller plays as well so yeah I rate
that scoring set up obviously like you
mentioned 50 points for an intercept
it's ah first five's eyes will be
lighting up mate you and I both
go for The Intercept big time so that
could be a 50-point play can you stack
your whole team backline with pins load
them up intercept Specialists how good
would that be that the other side of it
is there is negative points as well so
in particular kicking because most
fantasy teams should usually load your
side up with as many kickers but you
want your kickers to be kicking their
goals or else you're losing a fair
amount of points um you're only getting
two for a conversion and negative one
for a miss so
um doesn't really make it worth loading
your site up with kickers
but negative points were missed tackles
um turnovers obviously the big one red
cards negative 10 and I'm guessing that
includes an upgraded one as well so
that'll be one to watch but yeah like I
say very impressed with the point
scoring system so I want to follow and
make sure that you've got players that
are sort of suited to that
and the other one that they have in this
game is um Power Play So six boosters
they call it
um to use throughout the comp you've got
to use these wisely you get three over
the pool plays and three in the playoffs
and one is a triple Captain so triple
points for you for your player
um you've got to use that wisely that's
a huge momentum swinger if you can nail
your Triple cap then you've got a Super
Kicker which is double points on that
kicker but also missed so if he misses
them
um you could have a tough week with your
Super Kicker and also a defensive King
so that's double points for turnovers
intercepts tackles made or tackles Miss
so super hard to predict intercepts or
turnovers but um you're probably for
that one you want to be choosing a
player who's making big tackles and very
rarely misses them maybe in a kick heavy
side but where you're thinking to use
your boosters throughout the year all
right well as soon as you mention power
plays my eyes light up rainbows that's a
word that just really gets me going so
that's good stuff and that's creative
from them as well I really rate that
it's tough
I can imagine some people sledging them
in the stands that just cost them some
fantasy points so it adds a bit of extra
head noise not only are they trying to
get their team to win but they're also
trying to ensure that fantasy players
around the globe are happy
um the French fall back he's pretty
sharp off the tee and I think they'll be
backing themselves to go up in threes
this week as well so that would be a
good shot but like you mentioned I think
you've got to load up on these teams
these guys playing some of the Lesser
Nations and if you triple Captain
someone that scores a hat-trick you
could be in for a heck of a day 15
points for a try
you'd be almost uncomfortable off the
back of week one you're gone but oh the
one thing I'm gonna do with it I'm gonna
just see this first round I'm not going
to use any of those boosters this first
round I want to get a feel for how the
points sort of fly and then next week
I'll be looking for a heavy match up
maybe a game where I think there's going
to be a 50 point plus Victory and I'll
be trying to load up on the kickers or
Wingers and something in that game but a
couple of things to look out for because
I a few mistakes obviously new fantasy
players will be playing for the first
time so
even the experienced ones will fall for
this trap as well I'd imagine but save
your team this time in this Fantasy game
you have to save your team when you make
changes it's already happened to me a
couple of times where I've changed and
mixed my squad and I forgot to push that
save button so make sure when you've
make your trades save your side before
you leave it because you don't want to
be thinking you've got someone who
scores a hat trick you've triple capped
in them and you didn't save it don't
come to me at the next week and say
that's what you did because I have
warned you here also picking players who
aren't playing that's probably a massive
one because there is four sides that do
have a buy the Sam Owens Tongans
Portugal Uruguay if you've got any
players from those sides get them out I
see fikito as the second most own Center
so there's a huge era from a lot I think
it's 20 of the size of vikitar on this
side jordy's the third most owned Center
so come on guys uh if you're in this
water lad conference you need to be
better than that can't have your
Midfield of 50 toe and Geordie that's an
absolute crime with unlimited trades so
get the guys in there that you need and
also the last common mistake is going
with your heart not your head some
players are made for Fantasy
um some aren't you might love the guy
but if he's not a fantasy player not
everyone is I wasn't you've got to make
sure that he's not in your side no
matter how much you love the guy go with
your head go with the numbers and you
will have a good season what do you make
of those mistakes silly yeah I'm a big
hard overhead type of operator so I feel
like you're speaking to me directly
there mate I was yeah um in the NRL
terms you know I'm big on your Bunty
half hours and Co sometimes don't even
make the 17 you know but they they have
a special place in my heart so yeah I I
definitely need to to keep that in mind
um and and also like you mentioned just
having the unlimited trades it's so good
because you can roll out these whole new
teams and really to them to that week so
I think when I was doing my team the
first week I um maxed out on Fijian
players I was going all in there because
I was expecting a lot of tackle breaks
offloads and racking up some good points
there so keep that in mind too I think
there's a limit on how many players you
can have from each team so don't don't
try roll out a full 15 of uh one team
because they won't let you do that so
mix them up but yeah use this first week
as a bit of a testing ground
um find some players that you like and
that are going to score some good points
I think it's going to unearth some
hidden gems as well so I'm excited for
that yeah you'll you'll find a Wii
player in one of the listener and teams
and you'll fall in love with them
because he gets you a few fantasy points
he's a he's a Workhorse from Chile and
um then you've you become a fan for life
so I I can't wait to get stuck in and
see who comes up scoring big points
after the first round but we'll quickly
go through uh maybe our captain and
three other players that we think is a
good buy for this week obviously we
can't be sure on our teams yet because
World rugby have not made teams be named
earlier so teams are just going to hold
off until they have to name them which
absolutely breaks me as you know but
um I'll start I'll start with my captain
I've gone for the Irish Winger James
Lowe like I spoke about against Romania
I think he's going to be busy he's going
to be on the end of a couple I'll be
surprised if he doesn't score three and
there we go there's 45 points at least
to start double it we're looking at a
huge start for James Lowe if I knew and
was confident in this game I would
probably use my triple Captain but I'm
going to save that but I'm expecting
James Lowe to go hard early and have a
big start who's your captain going to be
yeah I was thinking maybe a Samu karivi
type of operators
um just because I really raid as
football he's in my Midfield with semi
radar address so I've gone the full
Fijian Flair there I mentioned I tried
to stick the team with 15 feet jeans I
found a bit of a loophole we can pick
some Aussie ones as well which for me I
think that's playoff on so I might go
Samu just because I expect line breaks
Galore
um and he's a heck of a footballer on
his day so hoping he can come through
but James low when you mentioned it I
thought that was some smart footy from
you but there's a bit of heart in that
as well I think you know Tasman man he
we all know you're a big fan so you've
comboed the two of them well yeah yeah
yeah I've purely gone my head your one
sounds way more hearty with Caribbean
than Midfield again which could be a
tough Georgia I don't know we'll we'll
have to see how that one's gonna go but
the other person I've gone this one's
probably more heart as well Jameson
Gibson Park I've paid the nine dollars
for him
um I just think in this game against
Romania
uh and the heat he will absolutely
relish it he loves his super fit he'll
find some nice support lines in that
heat um he'll have a few Snipes he'll
pick up a few triceps and I I predict
him to be the highest scoring nine of
the round I know DuPont's up there he's
around the 11 Mark you've got to pay the
big price for him won't be paying that
against the All Blacks but I'll be
picking him up at some point especially
when they're playing the Lesser size but
for me Jameson Gibson Park is my nine
and
um head and heart say that pretty strong
now that's a good shout I was gonna Fork
out for Dupont as well I made the rookie
mistake of just loading it up with
superstars and running out of the budget
with about six players still to film so
had to go back and and reassess there
and Dupont was one of the players that
that got cut so I do like Jameson I
think he's so important to that team
um he's almost like another 10 out there
for them so I expect him to play Big
minutes and in crucial games Ireland
have a a pretty tough pool as well South
Africa in there so I don't mind picking
teams where they're going to have to
roll out that best 15 for at least three
or four pool games I know you can trade
guys but when you find someone you like
the old pick and stick can come in quite
handy so yeah I don't mind picking
players that are going to play key roles
in in a tough pool yeah I expected them
to sort of rest those guys for this one
they've obviously got some massive games
coming up but good to see Island
obviously want to come out hissing from
the start and make a bit of a statement
against these guys so I guess the big
concern with jammo some Jamison Gibson
Park is that he gets the early shower as
sort of 40 45 minutes and he only gets
100 points instead of the couple hundred
I'm expecting so
you set the Benchmark eye
another one I've checked out there is we
spoke about them before as my first try
score about masarawa he's only 4.50 he's
an absolute bargain he's been lighting
up the Japan top league for the last few
years I think the Chileans will find
them very hard man to tackle he's a
tackle breaker line breaker he'll
probably score a couple I'm expecting a
big score from him as well
yeah that's a great shot I'm actually
jumping on my phone right now to uh
Chuck him in my team because uh that is
a great bargain buy I've just written
them down in my notes so I'll be doing
that once this wraps up and that's why
you tune in you know to get the heads up
on on selections like that that's uh
that's a great decision from you there
mate so yeah massaray will now be on the
wing at 4.50 a great buy absolute
bargain and I think another one you
mentioned before was uh Ramos the French
um fullback I think he'll be one to keep
a close eye on over the competition
obviously he's a goal kick a very sharp
shooter
um so a fullback I've actually got him
down to be my top Point scorer in the
competition fullback goal kicking for
air quality French side
um I I've gone home to be my top Point
scorer and my top try scorer this was in
the other game
um I've gone for wool Jordan
um a little bit of the heart there
because it's super hard to predict the
chop Choice girl but the man can cross
the line he finds his way to the trial
and almost every week and he only needs
to be playing in a couple of these um
lesser games where you know he could
score three or four pretty easy so who
have you gone for top Point score or try
scorer yeah it's a tough one because
like you mentioned with the try score as
I was going through some of the players
but you just don't know if he's going to
play against the Namibia or or whatnot
and that's where a guy like if Caleb
Clark gets the start he could easily bag
a hat trick and gonna shoot himself
right up into contention but you
definitely want a player from these top
sides that's going to go right their way
through the tournament
um I rate the shout on the French full
back too because
yeah Sharpshooter I I went into Mac was
ruled out I thought great that's a
massive blow for them but then you see
him just step up and bang everything
over
yeah they've lost nothing in the goal
kicking department so that is a good
shout there top try scorer I was gonna
go Mark to Leah but I think genuinely
that they won't play in those big games
so you want someone probably a chisel
and Colby let's go with the cheese oh
Colby cheese back them in because I
think South Africa you know a tough pole
Island and Scotland so I expect that
they'll have to play their best team for
the majority of those games and they're
also a team you see playing finals
football so hopefully chiseling can got
dot down but yeah there's some good chat
around like a Malcolm Mark something
like that as well I think hookers are in
for a massive tournament yeah mate
they're all good shouts and Colby he's
sort of gone under the radar a little
bit the kid can play man I love watching
that guy play so I'm looking forward to
seeing him go we've gone onto the
Instagram for some questions was a
little bit of a mix up we basically
nailed them all off um I guess the last
one is which player would be the biggest
loss for their team throughout this
World Cup who do you think for you which
team cannot afford to lose which player
man this is a tough one because straight
away your mind jumps to the pivots The
Playmakers because they kind of pull so
many of the strings but just on a New
Zealand sense someone I would hate to
lose will be an Arty surveyor I think
just his leadership without even being
the skipper is massive to our side
obviously we don't have the biggest four
pack going around but pound for pound is
one of the strongest players in World
rugby so he's a real follow me type of
operator and he's one of those guys that
the players turn to when the when the
times are tough during games so I think
if we're gonna go all the way and match
it with your South Africa your France
your Island up front Arty's gonna be key
for us so I'll Chuck him in and again
he's another bloke that has a special
place in my heart so I've got a bit of
heart there as well how about yourself
Matt he's also my fantasy team too he's
my only all back this weekend in my
fantasy side so
he's just he's just one of those special
players who can um he finds points and
fantasy all over the show with turnovers
line breaks he can do it all he's he's
such a talent so I'm looking forward to
seeing him do some of his best work on
the big stage so that's a great shout
um I think the two for me
um would be Sexton for Ireland I think
if they lose
um his his game driving and
um the way he controls that side is just
world class I think they'd struggle if
they do lose him and I think Dupont
having already lost intimac if French
lose Dupont I think they might just lose
that little bit of X Factor which they
rely so much on man I think it's the
best player in the world so if you're
going to lose that it can't help your
team's chances but
um yeah it's going to be an interesting
World Cup can't wait to get through this
first round see what scores come out of
it see what fantasy points come out of
it and see how you pull up after this
first game in Paris yeah hopefully I'm
I'm hoping to find some early form if
last night was to go by then I think I'm
off to a good start but you don't want
to Peak too early as well you know come
that final pool game is where you want
to start flexing what you've got so yeah
hopefully she's she's an uphill
trajectory from here but yeah you gotta
you gotta avoid
um Irish kiwi Aussie pubs there's a few
of them around and we seem to be the
biggest weapons that's for sure you know
the French they like to sit out have a
rose they start early they start at
midday with a rose and a and a ciggy
they're big on the darts over here so
you kind of avoid that but then they
also don't go out until about one or two
a.m so I start early knock off for a
sleep and then go hard again late
whereas us kiwis we're more just keep
going through so it'll be interesting I
might have to change the game plan mate
you've done a hell of a job to get up at
6am over there after getting home at 4am
and talk some absolute scents and real
facts throughout this um rugby real cat
preview so appreciate your efforts mate
and I'm obviously looking forward to
chatting with you next week and I'm
reviewing this first round and
previewing the next yeah hopefully
reviewing a big All Blacks win as well
because this will set the tone right if
we win this one then everyone will be
well and truly on board that the All
Blacks are going to win the thing so
that'll come with its own pressures as
well but I'm really excited for this
game obviously the atmosphere here is
building and people are kind of treating
this one as the final first up
um the French while they may not know a
lot of them may not know what's actually
going on over here at the moment they
all know and they all love the All
Blacks so they're saying this as that
game where if if the French can win this
I think it'll really ignite the
tournament over here and everyone will
jump on board because it will be massive
news mate how good you're getting me
right up the man with the most iconic
voice in the country speaking absolute
facts I saw that I saw that it was good
it was a compliment and then a bit of an
underhand blow as well just being like I
thought he was about 60 years old so I
rated that
um so like you always gotta gotta find
the compliment on everything so shout
out to that punter appreciate it mate
catch up next week how good Legend